it was
a fantastic new pink suit
with big buttons and shoulder pads
it was 1997 and i was the new boss
of griffin's foods an iconic cookie and
snacks company in new zealand
it was my first time as the leader of a
company and i was on the stage to give a
big
speech about our ambitious new goals
i knew exactly what my call to action
was which was one and every four times a
kiwi
eats a snack it'll be one of ours
i emphasized that we knew how to measure
our results
and that our future was in our control
embarrassingly enough i finished up with
if not this
what if not us who and if not now when
i got this huge round of applause and i
was really really pleased with myself
i wanted so much to be a good leader
i wanted to be followed by a devoted
team
i wanted to be right in short
i wanted to be a hero a hero selling
chips and biscuits
in a pink suit
what happened after that speech
nothing all of that applause
did not lead to action nothing changed
not because they didn't like me or the
message the problem was that no one knew
what they were expected to do
and most importantly they didn't know
that i needed them
now you may think that this is a classic
hero speech where i'm going to tell you
that i overcame that
obstacle and triumphed actually i'm
going to tell you
that in a world as complex and
interconnected as the one we live in
the idea that one person has the answer
is ludicrous
it's not only ineffective it's dangerous
because it leads us to believe that it's
been solved by that hero
and we have no role
we don't need heroes we need radical
interdependence
which is just another way of saying we
need each other
even though other people can be really
difficult sometimes
i spend decades trying to work out how
to be a good leader
i've lived in seven countries and five
continents
and in recent years i've spent a lot of
time with the b corp community
originally as a corporate participant
and more recently as an ambassador
now b corps saw a group of companies who
believe in business as a force for good
there's a tough certification with about
250 questions
about your social and environmental
performance
you must legally declare your intention
to serve the community as well as your
shareholders
and you must sign the declaration of
interdependence
now one of the things that inspires me
the most about the companies in this
movement
is that they see themselves as part of a
whole system
it's sort of as if they imagine
themselves on a big
flowing river of activity where
if they are for example soft drinks
manufacturers
they understand that upstream from them
there's water and sugar and farmers that
grow that sugar
and plastic and metal and glass
all of which flows into this thing that
we call a company which has financial
results
and the flowing continues with
consequences
some of them intended like refreshment
and hydration
and some unintended like garbage
and obesity spending time with leaders
in this space has led me to see that
true collaboration is possible but it's
subtle
and it's complex and the leaders in this
space are doing a few things
very differently from traditional heroic
leaders
they set goals differently they announce
those goals differently
and they have a very different
relationship with other people
let's begin with the first difference
a hero sets a goal that can be
individually delivered
and neatly measured you can recognize a
heroic goal
they use terms like revenue and market
share
and are often competitive i mean
remember pink suit day
interdependent leaders on the other hand
start with a goal that's really
important but is actually impossible
to achieve by one company or one person
alone
i want to give you an example from the
clothing industry which produces
92 million tons of waste a year
patagonia and eileen fisher are clothing
manufacturers
both of them be corpse both of them
deeply committed to reducing waste
they don't see that their responsibility
ends
when a customer buys their clothes
patagonia encourages you
not to buy new clothes from them and
will repair your old clothes for free
eileen fisher will pay you when you
bring back your clothes and either sell
them on
or turn them into other clothes while
these two companies are competitive in
some ways
they work together and with others in
the industry to solve
shared problems they take responsibility
for things that happen upstream as well
around the world there are around 300
million people who work from home
in this industry most of them women many
of them in
very difficult circumstances with poor
lighting
sewing on buttons and doing detailed
stitching
until 2014 there was no protection for
these workers
a group of companies got together with a
not-for-profit called nest
to create a set of standards that's now
been adopted by the whole industry
once you've seen problems like this you
can't unsee them
so you have to ask others to help you to
solve them these folks take
interdependence as a given and said to
me
we don't compete on human rights
the second big difference for
collaborators is their willingness to
declare their goals before they have a
plan
now the hero only reveals their
carefully crafted goal
when the path to achieve it is clear in
fact
the role of the hero announcement is to
set the stage for the big win
here our announcements are full of
triumph
interdependent leaders on the other hand
want other people to help them so their
announcements are often
an invitation for co-creation and
sometimes
they're a call for help at the north
american division of the french food
company dunon
i announced that we wanted to become a
bee corp
and unlike pink suit day i had no plan
to get there i remember the day really
clearly
everybody in the room gasped because
they knew
we didn't have a plan but
they also knew that we had seen our role
in the river that is the food system and
we wanted to make a change
making that declaration without a plan
meant that
so many young people in our company
stepped up to help us
and b-corps around us all rallied around
and the day we became a big corp wasn't
just the self-congratulatory moment of a
hero company
it was more like a community celebration
now when you have goals that you can't
achieve alone
and you've told everyone about them
inevitably you land up
at the third big difference which is how
you see other people
inside your company and outside
heroes see everyone as a competitor
or a follower heroes don't want input
because they want to control everything
because they want the credits
and you can see this in a typical hero
meeting
heroes like making speeches
people lean back in their chairs
maybe impressed but not engaged
interdependent leaders on the other hand
understand that they need
other people they know that meetings are
not just mindless calendar fillers these
are the most precious things you have
it's where people collaborate and
communicate and share ideas
people lean forward in meetings like
this wondering
where they might fit in
when i was in shanghai in china where i
lived for six years running the craft
foods business
selling amongst other things oreo
cookies
we had a problem with hero culture
we kept on launching new products that
failed and we would find out afterwards
that everyone in the company knew they
were going to fail they just didn't feel
free to tell us
so we changed the way we ran our
innovation and planning meetings in two
important ways
first of all language went back to
chinese
because even though everyone spoke great
english
when i was in the room and the meeting
was in english they focused on me and i
was the foreigner and i was the boss
and i apparently had that intimidating
hero look
the second thing is we asked every
single
person in the meeting their opinion
and our understanding of the subtleties
of the differences between
american taste and chinese taste in this
case
really improved and our new product
success rate
radically turned around and we launched
a lot of winners including the now
famous
green tea flavored oreos
hero culture sneaks in everywhere at the
known
we had a lot of great stuff happening in
one part of the world
and we wanted it to spread to another
part of the world
but when you put a person in business
gear up
in front of a group of people with
powerpoint they have the urge to become
sort of heroic and they make everything
look super shiny and they don't tell the
truth
and it's not compelling and it's not
even interesting
so we changed it and we created these
full day marketplaces kind of like a big
bazaar
and everybody was dressed up in costume
some people are little some people a lot
and sellers had to man their stalls and
sell their ideas as persuasively as
possible
and people who were convinced bought
them with fake checkbooks
creating just a bit of silliness with
the environment and a hat or a scarf
drops people's guard and causes ideas to
spread like wildfire
there's no recipe here but time
together has to be carefully
curated and created so that people know
that their
their time is valuable and and important
and they can bring their best selves to
the table
here are cultures present right here in
ted
this whole process makes it look like
i think i'm a hero so just in case
there's any doubt
about the point that i'm trying to make
i want to apply these ideas
in an area in which i have zero
credibility and zero experience
i'm originally south african and i'm
deeply passionate about wildlife
conservation
most particularly rhinos those majestic
creatures with big horns
every day three rhinos are killed
because there are people who think that
those
horns are valuable even though they're
just made of the same stuff
as hair and fingernails it breaks my
heart
like all good recovering heroes i did
everything i could to reduce this goal
to something that i could do by myself
but clearly stopping rhino poaching
is a goal way too big for me so i'm
immediately in
interdependence land i'm declaring my
goal
on this stage i found other people as
passionate as i am and have asked if i
can
join them and after today there may be
more
and we're now in the complex but
inspiring process of
learning how to work together my dream
is that one day
someone will stand on the stage and tell
you how radical
interdependence saved my beloved rhinos
why does hero culture persist and why
don't we work together more
well i don't know why everyone else does
it but i can tell you why i did it
interdependence is a lot harder than
being a hero
it requires us to be open and
transparent and vulnerable
and that's not what traditional leaders
have been trained to do
i thought being a hero would keep me
safe
i thought that in the elevation and
separation that comes from
heroic leadership that i would be
untouchable
this is an illusion the joy
and success that comes from
interdependence and vulnerability is
worth the effort and the risk
and if we're going to solve the
challenges that the world is facing
today we have no
alternative so we had better start
getting good at it
thank you